j'ai une question à te poser sur le rire
justement le j'ai oublié comment
s'appelait le comédien de doublage
original en fait le rire il le fait en
tapant sur sa glotte
[Musique]
est en fait je me demandais si toi du
coup tu t'inspires en faisant ça ou pas
du tout parce que moi j'aime ce cas
plutôt un truc de respiration mais c'est
plutôt comme ça
ouais je me fais pas mal
je ne les fait pas
moins fait de vrais en mer c'est moi où
est d'ailleurs et je ne suis pas pour
plaider cette voie là parce que lui elle
est vachement mieux sa vie ouais c'est
incroyable c'est un kit 5000 nous
citoyens
mais je me retrouve plus ou moins là
dedans mais je dis que c'est lui mais
c'est toi mon clown
parfois vous exposez à une amende
forfaitaire de 135 euros mesdames
messieurs s'il vous plaît par les temps
qui courent 135 euros ce n'est pas
négligeable
la
défense par exemple
pour éviter
ça fait longtemps maintenant plus un peu
de romantisme et dans ce monde de brutes
il
rappelant mais simplement pour le menton
de la bouche déjeuner inclus même si on
a un gros nez des lunettes comme moi
c'est vraiment pas facile
avait su aborder n'y a pas de voitures
barani de vente ambulante si vous n'avez
pas pris de quoi manger vers 6 heures le
jeune auteur du temps
ok
je comprends pas j'ai un problème avec
ma clé mc l'électrique tu sais je
comprends pas je n'arrive pas à ouvrir
ma bagnole c'est bizarre non c'est ce
qu'on pense être la pile où je sais
à banon